we now have a list of the first oldest
windsocks
of your team a direct allocation of
criminal and doing
bye donald trump from en in die de party
how it became necessary that of
this thing push in the trump regime
restoration so we've just excited
michael cohen transpersonal lawyer
esprit de guilty de chance shadows
accounts arthur camping finance
violations related to much money pete de
mysteries of the candidate who week in
week in c is donald trump
in this role i come see the idea about
any of the substance payments
much money  stormy daniels they had through
the gray and their own anything about
ja quickly fierce paris online en nel the
bug revelation is that michael cohen all
ages de harmony payments for which i
was convicted free which i prodotti
brother specifically directly a specific
new issues about them bye  donald
trump himself with the law allowed eyes
donald
trump criminals who for which michael
knhs plead guilty
michael cohen is cities in nola  n search
terms
dat die in lirop hey my teammate were
quote
the board or the kids opinion donald
trump control de to judge in the
district court in new york city
yesterday i set de de has many famous
for not only made as directed by trump
met de  remedies direct bike from
specifically for the principal purpose
of influence in the election
the question and media libie comes can
come and process or will be in a
location that happy substantial who is
local and is and evidence for the
millions of document exactly during the
course of the  investigation on the fbi
rated it hotel room en is off with and
this condo all meat is so is
very reasonable the tank de come
may have actually ever in stine try to
this request in garlic wheelchair the
site of water i in that squad
soon war  with a location of come
and likely minus the trump is as if guilty
of camping finance
a fraudster illegals who dark
chocolate discuss how my wie get
information about  this how my dp tastes
and the donald trump in that community cm
crimes
that michael cohen committed wel michael
collins nicer lenny dave is on joran
msnbc was to you recognize my the
castle and idea vcc
long time clinton phalarope bill and
hillary clinton
here is michael collins  prettier and g6 in
very clear charms the cabbage in the nose and
this willing to talk about trump
collusion know
rush article is in class eye catcher
idea ensure that question about
i go jack specifically michael and the
special council
range can tell you the mystique al  in
huis
nou in angers en subject that changes to
the special castle en is more than happy
to tell de special cancel 3a this
possibility all conspiracy
to close and could be working to make
system in 2016 election which de john
kerry opinion was earring rosso
knowledge about  the computer crime and
packing and whether or not
mr cheng new autumn shine
he bad guy compassionate shirt
domino walked on oakley show from
knowl  edge and packing and attempts to
oil
specifically about donald trump is what
one idea bcc with client michael cohen
house
lenny davis as if they michael cohen
testify the other also the from direct in
him
circular crime there is a media
development in this case
even wiggle wiggle  jenny davis okay so
far
lenie dv6 am true photo i fast who
been able to or operator plus 2 in css
thumping d'azyr and dat happening to many
davies is there dress here this is about you
champion explore and this i stars
finally be possible  level to feature
cover with it had got it right and
caleb the in compromise that should be
scared to everybody we dit is als er
willie gary and her family use
version of the property public the people
who voted for five in 2016
the people who had  old building in the mitch
arms were people talking about a month
the display
many of them do needed so is king on
and many of the ones that you don't have
the believe that this is actually annual
report  t nick condition successful
bye donald trump figure builds a and those
people no beauty and this and daryl and
that davison trump pause also already in the house
so a to that trump
debing condition to reflex or i think
speaks news one day here the staff and
spice what trump  is i think
since trading pictures from marley last
night like nothing is comin' on his
oxley pink and acquire on twitter and
trump
tensed ago bothered quiet when she
realizes that is can the net i think a
milli balance see this leder say something
along the lines  or popular for the
silent gagarin i think the color liessel
in the palm and for this copy party with
such a private deed come in file comment
prettier is an intermediate straw
who is who rise to improve oval window
she knows the president of the united
states  and the only' tassel with another
person is wil de huiss en adapt and the
answer
dairy you is a knife republic and jews
and nov the answer is a final and
anne kwier new republic in sar  contact
to impeachment
anlässlich an author a boat in
november its usually time on twitter
app die pacman and the show is on twitter
this task my show
we still got the entire palmaire for the
die with a product to talk about next
trace episodes my possible a park
dot com slash
had me knife spoken about the unfair en
dan fortunate stinkwater can be around
therapy je should be and better help
make things i van easier for you if you
and thinking about getting invalt en
working with their path to get access to
fully licensed experience het
psychologist and their path to your
phone or computer
oh you got it us go together helps art
com slash pacman de velar aggression and
the match o'er de counselor daryl works
best for you you can ask if i would
de juf terpen  snap religious of dat is
een point you
en het nip if i think you their business
naar i got it you can switch en
het summary els is less expensive than
cinq ans learn person verde  r help also
gives you unlimited access to your
account for your contacts dan every day
if you want you will not get up anger in
person
ernest chocola better hope com slash
jaw my solid sign up and get started
duplo link in the video description if
you  watch on youtube
check it out better help dot com slash
jp
nen